[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's adam levine brushing off someone
he didn't need over the weekend oh my
god that's so crazy yep it sure was and
et has an eyewitness account of the now
viral moment
here's what went down
on saturday adam's band maroon 5 was
jamming out at the hollywood bowl in los
angeles
[Music]
performing their hit song sunday morning
[Music]
[Applause]
but things took a turn when one fan
decided to get up close and personal
with the singer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in this video posted to tick tock you
can see the female fan rush on stage and
hug adam mid-song
after security escorts the woman away
the 42-year-old singer looks visibly
shaken from the interaction
according to the tick tock user who was
in the audience and shared the video the
woman snuck onto the right side of the
stage and quote came out of nowhere the
eyewitness tells et quote it all
happened so quickly the security guards
took her right away all of us were super
confused because we didn't know if adam
was joking or not
the video has since gone viral and now
boasts over 700 000 likes
[Applause]
[Music]
but before the bizarre incident fans
were living their best lives at the
star-studded event
a benefit concert put on by audacity
called we can survive
featuring artists like maroon 5 plus
doja cat shawn mendes the kid leroy cold
play and the black eyed peas
the show was a success raising over
dollars for the american foundation for
suicide prevention